Okay,
well so,
so that that's another issue in some
sense that seems to make the
postmodernist critique even more
correct.
How in the world and going to extract
out and canonical interpretation of
something like that.
It's like it's not possible,
but here's the issue as far as I can
tell the interpreter,
so in the postmodernists extended that
critique to the world,
they said,
look,
well,
a text is complicated enough.
You can extract out a canonical
interpretation.
What about the world?
The world is way more complicated than a
text and so there's an infinite number
of ways that you can look at the world
and so how do we know that any one way
is better than any other way?
And that's a good question.
Now the postmodern answer was we can't
and that's not a good answer because you
drowned in chaos under those
circumstances,
right?
You can't make sense of anything and
that's not good because
it's not neutral to not make sense of
things.
It's very anxiety provoking.
It's very depressing because if things
are so chaotic that you can't get a
handle on them,
your body defaults into emergency
preparation mode and your heart rate
goes up and your immune system stops
working and like you burn yourself out,
you age rapidly because you're
surrounded by nothing you can control.
It's varying.
That's an existential crisis,
right?
It's anxiety provoking in depressing,
very hard on people and even more than
that,
it turns out that the way that we're
constructed neurophysiologically is that
we don't experience any positive emotion
unless we have an aim
and we can see ourselves progressing
towards that aim.
It isn't precisely attaining the aim
that makes us happy.
As you all know,
if you've ever attained anything because
soon as you attain it,
then the whole little game ends and you
have to come up with another game,
right?
So it's sisyphus and that's okay,
but,
but it does show that the attainment
can't be the thing that drives you
because it collapses the game.
That's what happens when you graduate
from university.
It's like you're king of the mountain
for one day and then you're like surf
at,
at starbucks for the next five years,
you know,
so,
so what happens is that that human
beings are weird creatures because we're
much more activated by having an aim and
moving towards it than we are by
attainment.
And what that means is you have to have
an aim and that means you have to have
an interpretation and it also means that
the nobler aim,
that's one way of thinking about it,
the better your life.
And that's a really interesting thing to
know because you know,
you've heard ever since you were tiny
that you should act like a good person
and you shouldn't lie,
for example,
and you might think,
well,
why the hell should I not like a good
person?
Why not lie in even a three year old can
ask that question because smart,
smart kids learn to lie earlier,
by the way,
and they think,
well,
why not twist the fabric of reality so
that it serves your specific short term
needs?
I mean,
that's a great question.
Why not do that?
Why Act morally if you can get away with
something and it brings you closer to
something you want,
well why not do it?
These are good questions.
It's not self evident.
Well,
it seems to be tied in with what I just
mentioned.
It's like you destabilize yourself and
things become chaotic.
That's not good,
and if you don't have a no blame,
then you have nothing but but shallow
trivial pleasures and they don't sustain
you and that's not good because because
life is so difficult,
so much,
it's so much suffering.
It's so complex.
It ends and everyone dies and it's
painful.
It's like without a noble aim,
how can you withstand any of that?
You can't.
You become desperate and once you become
desperate things go.
Things go from bad to worse,
very rapidly when you become desperate,
and so there's the idea of the noble aim
and it's not something.
It's something that's necessary.
It's the bread that people cannot live
without,
right?
That's not physical bread.
It's the noble aim and what is that?
Well,
it was encapsulated in part in the story
of Marduk.
That's,
that's to pay attention.
It's to speak properly,
it's to confront chaos,
it's to make a better world.
It's something like that and that's
enough of a no blame so that you can
stand up without,
you know,
cringing at the very thought of your own
existence so that you can do something
that's worthwhile to justify your
wretched position on the planet.
So now there's a literary issue.
Is that.
So look,
you take a text,
you can interpret it a variety of ways,
but that's not right.
This is where the postmodernist went
wrong because what you're looking for in
a text and in the world for that matter
is,
is sufficient order and direction.
So then we have to think,
well,
what is sufficient order and direction
means well,
you don't want to suffer so much that
your life is unbearable.
Right?
That just seems self evident.
Pain argues for itself,
I think of pain as the fundamental
reality because no one disputes it,
right?
I mean even if you say that you don't
believe in pain,
it doesn't help when you're in pain,
you still believe in it,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's.
You can't pry it up with logic and
rationality,
it just stands forthe as as what the
fundament of existence and that's
actually quite useful to know.
Say,
well,
you don't want any more of that than is
absolutely necessary and I think that's
self evident and then you say,
wait a minute.
It's more complicated than that.
You don't want any more of that.
That's necessary today,
but also not tomorrow and not next week,
not next month,
not next year,
so however you act now better not
compromise how you're going to be in a
year because that would just be
counterproductive.
That's part of the problem with short
term pleasures,
right?
It's like active haste,
repented leisure.
Everyone knows exactly what that means,
so you have to act in a way that works
now and tomorrow and next week and next
month and so forth,
and so you have to take your future self
into account and human beings can do
that and taking your future self into
account isn't much different than taking
other people into account.
Right?
Because I remember there's this Simpson
episode and a homer downs,
a quart of Manet's and vodka.
He says,
I'm someone's.
Marge says,
you know,
you shouldn't really do that,
and homer says that's a problem for
future homer.
I share.
I'm sure.
Glad I'm not that guy.